bonjour je suis tel c'est ensemble que
nous allons découvrir l'histoire du
soulier
[Musique]
dans histoire de souliers nous allons
explorer l'univers de la chaussure
féminine de l'escarpin à la ballerine en
passant par la chaussure compenser les
bottines les bottes les mary jane
les cuissardes et toutes les autres
mais comme disait bette midler donné une
fille des chaussures correct et elle
peut conquérir le monde
dans histoire de souligner je vous dirai
tout sur cette arme de destruction et de
séduction massive les femmes et leurs
chaussures où la relation la plus
fusionnel qui soit avec un accessoire
votre vie ne sera vue et car la quête du
graal trouver la chaussure parfait
penchons nous sur son histoire et les
infinies possibilités offertes à nos
gens aujourd'hui dans l'histoire de
souliers vous découvrirez la bottine
comment cette chaussure connue de tous
at-elle frayer son chemin à travers
l'histoire pour devenir coach chaussures
qui ne laisse personne indifférent
adéquat vaut-il mieux porter ses
bottines retrouver nos professionnels de
la mode pour toutes les explications
vous découvrirez ensuite les conseils
locaux shopping de nos professionnels
qui vous révéleront les tendances du
moment vous aurez ce qui est totalement
hymne et ce qui est à ne pas faire pour
retrouver enfin notre rubrique hier deux
modèles les plus d'extravagant de la
haute couture et du design nous vous
présenterons des modèles de bottines
uniques en leur genre mais tout d'abord
vous avez peut-être un petit noah nous
dire sur cette chaussure si particulière
paris nous avons mené notre petite
enquête dans la capitale pour savoir
comment vous abordiez la bottine quels
conseils mesdames
ouais tu n'as que je prends vraiment
beaucoup c'est des petites boots en daim
avec des franges parce que c'est la mode
et ça ce portail vous et c'est vraiment
son appartement et low boots est ce que
je porte
actuellement il me semble les boots
était un petit peu plus haut au niveau
du mollet et l'époque c'est au-dessus du
mollet on a un goût pour moi c'est ça
qu'est ce que vous en pensez vous quelle
est la différence
une meilleure allure quand on marche et
c'est un peu plus classe je pratique les
boosts chaussures d'automne avant de
devenir la panoplie des femmes modernes
et d'être porté par toutes les stars la
bottine n'a pas toujours était glamour
directement inspirée de la botte qui est
avec la sandale une des plus anciennes
chaussures au monde
elle avait à l'origine une fonction
utilitaire observons maintenant qui est
l'ancêtre de ce bas salaires de la
chaussure
qu'est ce que la boot ou la bottine vous
évoque alors un côté un peu plus donc
toute façon ferme et donc du coup voilà
maïs idées moi je sais pas si on les
voit mais on a ici des modèles de
bottines donc juliette est parti sur un
corps en velours noir avec un talon de
shon qui du coup ça donne vraiment un
aspect enfin une excusez moi une vraie
gueule à la chaussure on voit très bien
que ce sont de vraies chaussures en cuir
et ses solides et en même temps ça donne
un côté très féminin et très sexy ce
qu'on veut dire par là c'est je vous
montre mais je couvre un peu mes
chevilles et ça c'est un vrai aspect
autant visuel que de perception des
autres quand on nous regarde évidemment
du coup ça donne un côté sexy et glamour
et en même temps très confort et on a le
pied complètement maintenu
c'est un avantage à toute épreuve donc
j'en montre suffisamment centraux pour
montrer ses seins rect voilà tout est
dans la suggestion c'est la suggestion
la voix de cidre et la boot ou la
bottine sont elles encore à la mode
oui elles sont définitivement à la mode
pour cet hiver la boots et la bottine ou
avec des incontournables de cet hiver il
faudra absolument en avoir des bottines
et également des low boots
j'y reviens car la low boots est une
sorte de modèle hybride entre la bottine
à l'escarpin qui a une coupe hyper sexy
sur l'avant du pied et qui en même temps
le maintien qui nous permet de marcher
toute la journée et voilà ce sera
vraiment en tout cas on ne pense
l'incontournable de cet hiver et là on a
la bottine du coup on a un côté encore
écossais assez funky à mettre avec une
petite robe noire ou un petit jean noir
ou même un jean
voilà un modèle hyper original qui va
cartonner cet hiver
[Musique]
j'explique que la bottine a détrôné
aujourd'hui la botte tout simplement
parce que maintenant il ya mieux que les
bottines gueule à l'aube août la low
boot remplace la bottine la botte et
d'escarpins et c'est vraiment l'article
qui est vraiment un outil fonctionnel
je pense que la logbook fonctionne pour
toutes les morphologies parce que elle
est par définition elle c'est une petite
boutique qui arrive à un niveau hyper
réseau vert parce que tout le monde ne
peut pas porter une bottine parce qu une
bottine peut couper la jambe une botte
peut couper la jambe une nos boutiques
ne coupera pas à la jambe bien
accessoirisé tout le monde pourra la
porter
[Musique]
oh
la botte est l'ancêtre de la chaussure
il suffit de regarder les peintures
rupestres vieilles de 13 mille ans et
représentant des bottes
elle est née dans les stats asiatiques
pour protéger des cavaliers du froid des
cailloux et protéger leurs jambes lors
des déplacements à cheval elle pouvait
même être fourré avec de la paille ou de
la laine pour protéger le pied du froid
pendant très longtemps les bottes et est
exclusivement réservé aux hommes
ce n'est qu'au début du 19e siècle que
les femmes puissent s'approprier ce type
de souliers vers 1830 les bottes ont
commencé à raccourcir pour devenir des
bottines et entrer ainsi dans un
garde-robe des élégantes
[Musique]
oui
elle avait pour but de cacher le pied et
la cheville des femmes qui représentait
de vraies attentes à sion mais l'effet
fait exactement l'inversé
au lieu de calmer les ardeurs les
bottines largement la c est étroite
suscitèrent des passions ardentes
pour preuve la bottine et la chaussure
phare des danseuses de french cancan
[Musique]
au 20ème siècle les bottines sont
vraiment devenus des pièces de mode cuir
velours broderie boutonnage les bottines
par leurs grandes surfaces offrent une
liberté de création sans limite
c'est courage qui lança au même titre
que la fameuse mini jupes des bottines
plates beige complètement polyvalente
ces chaussures sont devenu un best
seller et ont été très largement imité
[Musique]
pour moi la bottine et les low boots
sont devenus incontournables avec la
grande vague marais du casual chic
d'aucune low boot logo témoin
structurantes et structurée avec une
botte ac - couvrante donc les filles
retrouvent une certaine liberté dans une
beauté inouïe low-boots qu'elles vont
pas forcément dans une botte le bottines
ou le low boot qui m'a marqué le plus
c'est une qui est dans ma collection à
moi donc c'est le freelance en 1981 donc
c'est peut-être la première fois que
j'ai vu une beauty news l'aube août au
canada
donc il est arrivé ce produit au canada
je les portais jusqu'à l'année dernière
je les fais emmené aulas cordonnier au
moins onze fois et finalement il m'a
informé que il a respiré ces dernières
ces dernières souffle de vie et
maintenant c'est juste dans mon placard
et pourquoi ce que je laime parce que
dans ces produits il y avait un côté
masculin féminin qui venait de nulle
part à cette époque est le talon était
très présente en 2013 la bottine
c'est vraiment des morts démocratiser
donc je vois des jeunes filles en jupes
et robes même en été dans leurs bottines
il y a des petits modèles sandales
il y à toute une diversité de bottines
donc je dirais qu'aujourd'hui il n'y a
plus de limites sur le petit on fait ce
qu'on veut
que la boot vous évoque la brousse c'est
l'entrée de saison d'hiver pourquoi
parce que avant de passer par la botte
il ya toujours la pousse cette saison-là
doute c'est toujours très low boots on a
déjà vu cette tendance pour l'hiver
dernier cette saison là en fait on a des
tiges très courte systématique qui font
que on a un peu l'esprit d'un escarpin
et bien que ce soit une goutte voir le
bruce donc la low boots pour moi c'est
vraiment le la it shoes de la saison on
en fait beaucoup
vraiment nous dans la collection c'est
un produit auquel on dise on croit
beaucoup plus tôt compensé a donc avec à
chaque fois le plus patins plus ou moins
important et puis voilà chaque fois un
talon assez assez haut pour la rendre
plus fine et du donné quand même un
style un peu plus aérien et donc la
boucle
pour moi c'est l'incontournable de
l'hiver c'est quelque chose qu'on va
mettre en début de saison
vers la fin septembre et puis voilà il
ya des saisons c'est plus important que
d'autres cette saison là elle et elle va
être encore je pense vraiment au devant
de la scène parce que à la mode fait que
c'est qu'un petit peu moins de 2 de
jupons mais plutôt d'un pantalon donc la
bourse avec le port d'annoncer tout
simplement impeccable
on essaye aussi de se renouveler avec ce
genre de produit donc on a à la fois
voilà des choses très courte et puis
après on est allé qui j'ai un petit peu
plus haute
et puis voilà on va essayer de
travailler pas mal sur les matières avec
notamment des matières un petit peu plus
travaillé avec les cuir imprimé comme
celui ci pour la rendre un titre
boutet est un incontournable pour
l'hiver oui une nouvelle fois et surtout
cette saison parce que parce que il ya
la boots et puis elle a low boots et
c'est vrai que la halle au bout ce sont
là comme je vous dit c'était déjà il y
avait une naissance comme l'hiver
dernier
et puis voilà ça va être cette saison là
ça n'aide vraiment le produit je pense
de l'hiver ont commencé on l'a vu dans
les carrés clémence et puis voilà on
commence donnant à voir dans les
magazines donc c'est quelque chose qui
va être encore on va qu'on va beaucoup
voir dans les boutiques et puis j'espère
aux pieds nos clients
[Musique]
qu'elle soit là c'est à boucles plates
ou encore à talons la bottine a
quasiment remplacer la boîte dans mon
coeur et surtout dans nos placards
asociaux plus polyvalent qu'une paire de
bottes elle va plus facilement avec
différentes tenues et protège le pied
sans lui thoniers prochain elle a
également loupé beaucoup plus moderne
pour parler en langage le bottier on
utilise le terme de bottines quand cette
chaussure autres contient des lacets et
dans tous les autres cas on va plutôt
parler de boot
elle a une tige au to be hot et elle
peut être plate ou avec des talons la
bottine est un des modèles phares des
créateurs de haute couture et des
designers pour leur collection d'hiver
et il faut bien dire qu'en tant que
chaussures aux matières et aux
dimensions tellement déclinable elle
offre des possibilités de création hors
du commun
c'est pourquoi on constate que l'accent
est souvent mis sur un message
artistique qui peut être très éloignée
des considérations vestimentaire comme à
son habitude le controversé alexander
mcqueen fait encore dans la provocation
en réinventant la bottine sous forme de
pince de crustacés cette inspiration
originale se poursuit avec le modèle
steampunk des low boots plutôt moderne
et les modèles aliens complètement
déjanté dans son éternel fibre baroque
mcqueen nous présente également ses
boots à talons dorés et ornés de bijoux
et de strass chez hyundai mignot nous
retrouvons des bottines haute mais son
salon en cuir sculpté ou incrusté de
strass et de paillettes
dans un style plutôt sobre jamais elle
explore les matières hivernal pour des
modèles dont l'originalité est dans les
détails
talon en forme de morceaux de place ou
encore salon cristal pour ses modèles a3
matière en dentelle à mi chemin entre la
bottine et marie jeanne
dans la série jeune surdoué de la mode
cool ayoola sont deux créatrices
finlandaise qui allie forme ludique
couleurs vives et expérimentations
structurelles amber verte et guen est
une étudiante qui s'intéresse tout
particulièrement à l'interdépendance de
l'art et de la mode modèle de godspeed
jeunes issus de sa collection originale
situe à l'été anastasia radio est une
créatrice de chaussures qui a travaillé
avec notamment alexander mcqueen
elle n'hésite pas à utiliser de
nouvelles matières ou technologie dans
ses créations comme la fibre optique
elle est aussi à l'origine d'une
collection de chaussures intitulé love
civilisation avec des matières évoquant
des formes de vies disparues
une attitude marconnet de l'association
d'un architecte et d'un cordonnier
propose des modèles très structuré leur
collaboration avec la créatrice irin van
verten débouche sur des formes
innovantes et moderne modèle semble
plutôt classique ou la semelle est le
talon en forme de crosse font tous les
fai ou au contraire modèles dont
l'entrelacement complexe des manières
réclame une fabrication minutieuse
entièrement manuelle chez dsquared ce ne
sont pas des crocs mais des talons en
forme de colonne vertébrale qui
soutiennent des low boots toute simple
dans un esprit voisin
iris schäfer stein utilisent des animaux
morts comme partie intégrante de ses
créations aboutissant à des bottines
composé de pâte de chevaux appuyé sur un
talon pistolet
dans une toute autre démarche kobi levi
connu pour ses modèles originaux
attendant celui qui fait quotidienne
propose son modèle à talant chewing gum
[Musique]
enfin manu batista oeuvre aussi dans
cette veine heures avec ses bottines
brillante en forme de pomme croquée
[Musique]
mon conseil shopping pour les boots et
les bottines donc voici des modèles de
bottines donc la bottine monte un peu
haut sur la cheville
généralement elle à une fermeture éclair
sur le côté il est toujours préférable
d'avoir la fermeture éclair à
l'intérieur du pied comme ça on ne la
voit pas à la marche
voilà c'est mon petit zizi conseil ou
alors à l'extérieur comme ça ça nous
permet de glisser notre pied facilement
dans la bottine et après d'être à l'aise
toute la journée alors la bottine on
peut les espoirs hyper sobre et du coup
avoir une tenue un peu plus rock'n'roll
voilà une robe en dentelle un besoin
jean des couleurs un peu visible des
collants noirs ou alors oser des modèles
un peu bijoux tout en paillettes qui
vont super bien avec un jean une chemise
blanche un petit tee shirt noirs une
tenue un peu sobre et hop la bottine
rock and roll is la tenue voilà un autre
exemple super pour cet hiver pantalon
noir ou juste jean brut chemise blanche
et hop une petite bottines kilt
il ya également la low boot donc la low
boots et quand on veut être un peu sexy
c'est une chaussure un peu plus de
soirée donc je vais vous montrer donc la
low boots pour la choisir
mieux vaut une fermeture éclair sur
l'arrière pour qu'elle n'en tiennent
bien le pied et qu'on ait pas de mal à
rentrer dedans on peut couper ça c'est
mieux
donc voilà la low boots un décolleté
c'est un modèle hybride entre l'escarpin
et la bottine un décolleté qui couvre le
pied mais qui en même temps est hyper
sexy et qu'il à se découvrir la cheville
moi je la conseille en plate forme pour
pouvoir s'amuser un peu avec le talon et
la plateforme dans des matières qui sont
plutôt pas trop sobre du poil de la
paillette voilà c'est vraiment un modèle
avec lequel on peut s'amuser qui va
parfaitement habiller une petite robe
noire pour une soirée et enfin la
richelieu donc la richelieu c'est un de
mes modèles chouchou ça va vraiment avec
tous on peut la faire soit sabres soit
vraiment s'amuser
et nous c'est décidément en souliers on
aime bien s'amuser mettre plein de
couleurs sur la richelieu
voilà pour ce faire des petits modèles
un peu rigolo un peu vintage on s'amuse
également avec les lacets et l'appareil
savez avec tout une jupe noire un
collant noir un jean avec n'importe
quelle tenue on peut associer nos
petites chaussures un peu pepsi un peu
rigolote
voilà en talons hauts ou pantalons - o
donc là c'est un pied de poule voilà
super pour cet hiver un pull un peu
décalé un peu vintage un jean et des
richelieus pied de poule alors mon
conseil de shopping sur la low boots on
peut l'apporter idéalement est bien avec
ce qu'on veut c'est vraiment le modèle
idéal pour tous portés en 2013 c'est la
tendance à la low boots et la ballerine
donc comment choisir il l'aube août pour
qu'on ait bien chaussé et qu'on est
jolie je dirais la première chose à
regarder ces sept volumes
ici la claque donc en fait selon la
femme elle aurait plus ou moins de
matière là et c'est souvent lié avec est
ce qu'elle a fait la danse classique ou
pas donc une fille qui a fait beaucoup
de danse classique attendant c'est avoir
un peu plus de matière ici c'est musclé
donc ça c'est essentiel
et pour moi la tendance que je comprends
pas c'est tout le monde qui cherchent à
couvrir vous marchez venir avec une
low-boots si j'ai une chose à dire à
tous les fils et le fait pas
la cheville c'est une des choses qui
vous met en valeur donc pour moi c'est
une grande évidence qu'on trouverait et
low boot qui met en valeur sa cheville
au quel autre chose que je dirais
avantageux avec une low boots et qu'on
peut mettre une talent en chine et on
peut mettre une talent plus fort en
restant esthétique donc ça c'est
intéressant tu es en plus portés avec
une ligne aussi bien qu'avec une jupe
pendant le temps le temps dans ce but il
low-boots une chose qui va venir de plus
en plus fort si cette matière là donc ça
c'est une dentelle qui auparavant
étaient pas très utilisé parce qu'on
avait du mal à l'utiliser dans le
chausseur est ici cette dentelle là est
une dentelle chaussures
donc on commence à voir les premières
boules obut mêmes potes fait dans dix
d'entre elles et pour moi ça c'est une
tendance intéressante
quel est votre conseil look pour la
boucle la boucle
pour moi c'est beaucoup plus pantalon
que de jupes ou robes de manière pas non
plus casser trop la jambe parce qu'une
goutte
tout dépend si jamais elle a juste eu la
cheville ou danse car c'est plus humeur
univoque
mais voilà au dessus de la cheville pour
moi ça doit être systématiquement avec
un pantalon et quand elle est un petit
peu plus basse comme halo gouttes
c'est extrêmement gelé avec un pantalon
mais voilà c'est vraiment en tout cas la
paire qui se met pour toute circonstance
toute occasion
et puis à la fois qui peut avoir un look
week-end et puis en même temps avoir un
côté un petit peu plus habillée si
jamais on l'apprend haute et en daim
noir alors petit récapitulatif les
conseils de nos professionnels
concernant la bottine mesdames n'hésitez
plus pour être tendance aux et
l'originalité
que vous soyez plutôt bicolore plutôt
poils d'animaux ou les deux surtout ne
vous privez pas la tendance est à
l'audacieux les low boots en soirée
révéler la face sexy de vos jambes en
préférant des bottines assez courte
les matières de qualité pour des
produits durables investissez dans le
dain par exemple en revanche éviter que
la fermeture éclair sur l'extérieur à
moins de contribuer à un certain effet
ce n'est pas très esthétique les jambes
découverte ce qui est valable pour la
botte
elle est en effet aussi pour la bottine
plus la chaussure se charge de couvrir
jambes - les vêtements doivent s'en
charger veillez donc à porter des
collants ou un pantalon avec vole au
goutte à la bottine et la chaussure
hivernale par excellence c'est une
alternative plus pratique à la botte et
elles couvrent tous les styles possibles
et imaginables que ce soit la boot de
motards la bottines lacées version mary
poppins où c'est la boucle vintage elle
est plus moderne que la botte est
réussie l'amalgamme d'être cool et sexy
une garde-robe réussie doit proposer
plusieurs types de bottines pour être
complète car tous les modèles n'ont pas
le même effet parmi les indispensables
laboute motarde est une valeur sûre en
cuir gras
pourvu qu'elle ait rapidement un air de
déjà vécu comme si vous aviez passer des
week-ends entiers dans la boue d'un
festival de rock
un autre base c'est l'air et la bottines
noires à petits talons
celle-ci ne vous décevra jamais petite
robe habillée ou jean elle ira avec tout
ne fait pas l'impasse sur la qualité
elle vous suivra longtemps et si vous
voulez faire une petite folie choisissez
un modèle original pailleté animaliers
ou en cuir coloré la boot est une vraie
bête de scène qui portera le reste de
votre look
à très bientôt pour la suite histoire de
souliers
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]